I think it's really important to show
your true and authentic face to the
world if you don't know who you are
and you're not presenting that to the
world how are other people gonna know
who you are
I'm Eddie gyro Jones with an X on the
end and I am a member of the legendary
house of cards on and I walk between and
drags runway makeup led me to being able
to explore my gender on my own terms
being non-binary is literally going to
get to gender construct that society has
set for me gender is like a shower
nozzle where it's like you have hot you
have cold and you have everything in
between
nobody is all hot nobody's all cold it's
just what you've been allowed to explore
in your day to day life
makeup is like my armor for my daytime
face I don't do like a triple stack
flash that's for the ball that's where
nothing
makeup has always been a tool in my
community for people to be the person
they are or who they really want to be
and I think that's the best way to sum
up a ball I can be this person in this
ballroom and this is setting me up to be
this person out in the real world as
open a suburban community is many may
think that gender roles are like no big
deal which is completely incorrect
every category has female figure and
male figure but that's not necessarily
how I identified I've seen categories
like androgynous face that's a huge step
towards breaking those gender roles and
I think is really going to be ground
shaking I think in today's world there
are way more representations of all
types of people expressing themselves
through hair beauty and makeup and it
just really helps children to see there
is someone else out there like you and
they're doing it that's really what my
work is here to do
alright ladies and gentlemen this is the
final panel
[Music]